está rusia dispuesta a reducir los
combates en ucrania el presidente
estadounidense joe biden no está tan
seguro
ya veremos
no me gusta decir nada hasta que no vea
cuáles son sus acciones veremos si
cumplen con lo que sugieren sin los
comentarios se produjeron después de que
el ministerio de defensa de rusia dijera
el martes que reduciría la actividad de
las tropas en torno a dos ciudades
incluida la capital ucraniana tras la
más reciente ronda de conversaciones en
turquía la delegación rusa en estambul
dijo que se estaba preparando un acuerdo
sobre la neutralidad y el estatus no
nuclear de ucrania el objetivo principal
según el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores de turquía que estaba
mediando era impedir que aumentara el
número de muertos la principal prioridad
es lograr un alto el fuego lo antes
posible y allanar el camino hacia una
solución política sostenible ya que esto
es lo que siempre destacamos esta guerra
que ha provocado la muerte de miles de
personas y el desplazamiento de millones
debe terminar ya los negociadores
ucranianos insistieron en que cualquier
acuerdo requeriría garantías
internacionales de seguridad el
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selenski
confirmó que las conversaciones
mostraban signos positivos pero expresó
su cautela
morgan más debate pues si podemos decir
que las señales que escuchamos de las
conversaciones son positivas pero estas
señales no pueden silenciar las
explosiones de los proyectiles rusos
nadie es visto máximo por supuesto
estamos viendo todos los riesgos por
supuesto no estamos viendo motivos para
confiar en las palabras procedentes de
los representantes del país que sigue
luchando por destruirnos debate serán de
nación que insiste en que se permita a
ucrania solicitar la adhesión a la unión
europea los negociadores dijeron que la
cuestión de crimea en las regiones sin
vida de donbass se trataría una vez
alcanzado el posible acuerdo de paz